tech giants facing fierce backlash from
conservatives and claims of censorship
after two major social media crackdowns
twitter
permanently banning president trump from
its platform days after the siege on
capitol hill
an apple google and amazon all pulling
the plug on parlor
the so-called conservative twitter the
ceo of that company
now fighting back he's suing amazon
after the app was suspended
by its web service republicans say the
moves amount to silencing
their voices we're now living in a
country
where four or five countries companies
unelected unaccountable
have the power a monopoly power to
decide we're going to wipe
people out the effect of this is that
there is no longer a free and open
social media company or site for
any american to get on any longer well
the social media platforms
i mean they're completely inconsistent
so so they'll crack down on
conservatives
but what when the ayatollah says he
wants to get rid of the jews he wants to
demolish israel that's okay with with uh
with the social media platform and the
backlash now extending beyond just
social media
many corporations halting donations to
republicans
who voted to overturn the election and a
payment processing company says it is
cutting ties
with the trump campaign's website dana
the
justification that many of these
companies the websites are giving
is the prospect of violence they say
that violence was being encouraged
the president might have been
encouraging a repeat of the kind of
violent episode we saw at the capitol
whether on the 17th or at the
inauguration do you buy it
well i think that there's two questions
that come to my mind one is
a can and the other is should so on the
can
can the companies do this like is it
legal
there could be some argument about that
but from my perspective i think that
private as we've said for a long time
private companies have the right to do
this
at this point up until there is some
sort of antitrust
decision and you know that just got
started against google and facebook by
the justice department
those can take years to resolve and i
remember that because i dealt with the
microsoft lawsuit that the clinton
administration filed
uh on its antitrust issue it didn't get
resolved until i believe
uh late 2002 when i was at the justice
department so those things can take a
long time
but the other question is you know
should you do it and
i think that's where the real argument
is like should all of these people
uh be silenced um did
parlor uh abuse it's to own terms of
service did it abuse apple's terms of
service all of these things
um could be argued in court but the
problem is it's all these huge momentous
decisions
are being taken in the heat of the
moment
and the nation in my opinion really
needs a circuit breaker
like immediately as to the companies
that are making decisions again
first amendment right you don't have to
donate to anyone
you don't have to hire anyone but do you
have to make big announcements about it
like the forbes folks right
like so you're saying that say somebody
was the
assistant press secretary at the
department of energy
and a company decides to hire that
person because they
like her experience that forbes would
basically black list that company
because of that decision
i mean that's how deep it is getting i
understand holding
and the desire to want to hold somebody
to account for what happened last
wednesday because the more we learn
about it the worse it gets
and it's horrible and it could have been
so much worse than what it was so i
understand the concerns about the
violence i know that the fbi now is
saying
that there is talk of attacks against
state capitals
uh before the 20th that there are
additional things that are happening on
this
january 17th or possibly january 20th so
i get that they want to be responsible
but i do think that these decisions are
being made in the heat of the moment
and everybody needs to have cooler heads
to prevail
jesse uh in fact the pga is pulling
tournaments away from trump golf courses
but you also have as dana was saying
marriott dao
jp morgan hallmark blue cross american
express
pulling donations from politicians who
voted
uh not to certify the biden victory what
do you think
oh they can ask someone else for money
my thing is this one
twitter nuked donald trump for two
specific tweets they said they found
offensive one was when the president
said he wasn't going to go to the
inauguration
they said that incited violence and the
other is when he said his voters
had a giant voice they said that
glorified
violence you know that's bs and
everybody knows it's bs so i just want
to establish that
the american people do not need an
unelected ceo
to protect us from words uttered
by a president who we elected ourselves
we don't need it right now this is a
an offensive against the president that
started a very long time
and we saw it happen in slow motion
remember they first started to black out
his press conferences then they started
to black out his rallies
then they blacked out his
accomplishments and blacked out any news
that would have helped him
win reelection aka hunter biden's laptop
all right and now they have monopolies
amazon facebook twitter all of these
companies the strongest most powerful
wealthiest corporations in the entire
world
and they have now conspired with the
media and the democrats
to re-engineer the infrastructure of the
internet
to crack down on their political
opponents and
their market competitors juan you know
in the early
20th century teddy roosevelt came in and
we went after these monopolies one big
railroad
and one big oil company because too much
wealth and influence was concentrated in
those hands
and he rightfully busted them up joe
biden needs to bust these guys up
he won't because he's in bed with him
and it scares me as an american because
joe biden's
penchant for political surveillance you
remember what he did to the trump
campaign
you remember what he did to mike flynn
is going to merge with silicon valley
who basically own everything we do on
the internet
and they're going to go after and target
political speech
and political association and at that
point our country
is in deep trouble and only only
me only i am going to be able to save
the country at that point
well we're going to protect your right
to speak out jesse but i i was concerned
about the level of violence
they you know it man but degan i i mean
they're even closing the washington
monument to
tours now because of fear of more
violence and we're not talking about
violence by
al qaeda or isis they're fearing
us domestic terrorism in the united
states
and of course what we saw last week was
domestic violence so
something something is in the air beyond
trying to silence
some conservatives uh not after the fact
one uh glenn greenwald
defamed journalist is reporting he said
do you know how many people arrested in
connection so far
with the capital invasion where active
users of parlor
zero the planning was largely done on
facebook and their mechanisms in
our law enforcement and even to stop
this
before it happens number one but this is
what jesse said
this is about the power of the tech
monopolies
that they will censor silence and shut
down and put away
any business or any individual speech
they see fit the reason this is
happening right now my opinion
is because the democrats won in georgia
and you have the democrats controlling
the senate
and the house and the white house and
these tech giants know there will be
no repercussions coming out of
washington they're going to do what's
been going on
on in schools and on college campuses
across this nation
you silence dissent you silence
differing opinions
and if you're a conservative or speak a
conservative thought
they will shut you down and i just want
to point out that
chan the chancellor of germany angela
merkel came out
and said the right to freedom of opinion
is of fundamental importance
she called the president's accounts
being shut down
problematic the leftist president manuel
lopez obrador in mexico came out
against what these two these silicon
valley giants are doing
and also alexi nalvani the russian
democracy advocate who was poisoned last
year
against what's going on this is the
moment for
everybody to speak up and to stand up
for the speech that they hate the most
because if anybody knows history they
know these companies aren't just going
for conservatives they'll end up coming
for you too
that's a good point so brian i'll let
you wrap us all up here in this first
segment
but wouldn't you brian be outraged if
there was a
left-wing president who was inciting
mobs to violently storm the capital
threaten our representatives stop a
constitutional process
wouldn't you say oh my gosh the left is
out of control they should do
something about it first off i am really
enjoying the show
uh it's off to a great start i hope i
don't screw it up um
you're right uh but uh donald trump was
not saying go take the capital he was
going go protest at the capitol
he wasn't saying take the bike racks and
throw him i will say this one to your
point
there are people who support donald
trump that are really scary
and they're scaring people who support
donald trump like
congressmen that have been by his side
the whole time like senators that want
to get on a plane
that just decided that on this one vote
when it comes to the electoral process
they couldn't go along
like a vice president that's been
remarkably loyal
to more loyal than anyone else in my
lifetime from dick cheney to al gore to
um to any other vice president to hubert
humphrey i've never seen anything like
it
and provide for all of a sudden enemy
number one to be
mike pence and lindsey graham and tom
cotton
i think there's a little bit of a
problem with trump supporters they got
to reign in
a couple of things i think are important
to point out you are taking down donald
trump
in particular and you're destroying his
private business the pga
is doing their part and now all these
other companies that do business are
doing their
part do you really going to think it's
going to be great to rent a condo and a
trump tower
or a business in a trump tower in a
different city or go to a golf course
and get a membership in scotland
they are trying to hurt him in every way
shape or form they still
fear him and as uh as jonathan swann
said last night there's no indication
that donald trump's base has been hurt
other republicans have
left him perhaps murkowski and company i
get it
but after that no i will say this the
parlor thing is the most uh
disconcerting thing yet because they're
an emerging app
and you know why i know this is all
about politics and business
because the twitter ceo mocked the fact
with an emoji
their parlor the fastest growing app in
the country maybe the world
was now neutralized and i thought google
was in competition with apple
you know you want to go get an apple
phone or a google phone yes they are
but they all agree on one thing they
want no other competitors
so that's monopoly on paper they're
competing
but not in real life and that's what's
got to stop the sad thing is
uh juan it's not up to jesse it's up to
you it's up to you to tell democrats to
say
just because they're siding with you it
doesn't mean we should
keep regulation and uh and regulation
230
in place they should step up and
understand this is going to bite them in
the butt soon too
elizabeth warren wants to do that
there's like a big constituency
yeah there's a big constituency amongst
the democrats that wants to take a apart
230 as well that's why i think it
actually could happen
but if you get rid of 230 it'll actually
create it create
if they get rid of 230 you will get more
censorship
not less of it all right agree ladies
and